le top 5 des menaces sur la france
aujourd'hui je vais classerait ainsi la
première menace c'est comment la menace
actuelle il ya la menace djihadiste avec
des organisations comme al qaïda ou
l'état islamique que tout le monde
connaît les groupes terroristes dans
différentes régions du monde voire sur
le sol national la deuxième ne lassent
très probablement une puissance moyenne
armés de deux armes de destruction
massive chimiques nucléaires et qui
n'hésite pas à menacer voir employer
cette arme là la troisième menace c'est
une grande puissance qui après une
période de dérive autoritaire
on vient à passer de la compétition un
peu désinhibé a carrément l'acte de
force
la quatrième menace je dirais c'est pas
une menace à son franc parler c'est un
scénario un scénario de chaos des
accidents des événements climatiques ça
qu'il fasse que l'insécurité globalement
dans une région du monde est très
importante et nécessite l'emploi de
l'armée enfin la saq et menaces ça
pourrait être un peu imaginer une menace
ainsi conjoncturelles ponctuelles sur
tel territoire d'outre-mer ou contre des
ressortissants français qui
nécessiterait là encore l'intervention
de l'armée